it seems maybe I'm reading this wrong
but people are passionate now they're
like they have assessed this virus
they've assessed the shutdown we know
it's ravaging we've seen it a lot of
lives were saved the measures been
extraordinary a medical mobilization
that will be studied forever what do you
think about what's going on here there's
something building and it seems real
well some of America's always craved
their own liberty their own freedom you
know it's interesting with governor
Gavin Newsom decision Orange County why
did he pick Orange County this is some
of the best beaches in the entire
country Huntington Beach Surf City USA
they have some of the best lifeguards
but the local City Council actually
voted to allow them to open up in a safe
manner and when I look at those
protesters where your mass practice
social distancing we should do something
even better in this process but we can
open up in a safe manner moving forward
and that's what these cities are asking
for it let them have local control just
as the president gave gave governors the
ability to have local control as well
why wouldn't he honor that with cities
knowing best you know I think that as a
person that handled as the best as Ron
de Santos high elderly population yeah
targeted them New York a disaster
Michigan a disaster Cal Gavin Newsom did
a lot better than New York and Michigan
by far I was on the phone with governor
Newsom yesterday and I thanked him for
how he worked with the president and the
president working with him it was a very
good example I watched the president
talked with him today about his press
conference with the governor New Jersey
praising him telling telling the
president thank you for getting all
those ventilators a life-and-death
situations moving things the president
moving a navy ship here for a hospital
just like he did in New York amazing
things that we have done now the thing
that we can do remember we're talking
about a beach inside the heat this is
not a good place for the virus to live
but if the if those on the beach could
practice social distancing just as you
saw in that video that they were I think
we could open some up and let the locals
control how we go about doing that 187
days
Donald Trump saved New York no
politician in New York there's a big
election count yeah what there's a big
election and what I'm saying is Congress
Congress needs to get back to work the
thing I will tell you it's doctors
delivery drivers dispatchers they're all
working to help in this pandemic but the
Democrats are not you're right the
elections coming up people need to go to
take the house.com to have a Congress
that will work with them and work with
this president because what you have
talked about with Flynn and what the
president is bigger than Watergate and
we need to make sure people are held
accountable well said
Thank You congressman